not to applaud tricks from the poly
sci-fi movie The Manchurian Candidate -
loudly but anybody noticed that days
later we aren't debating whether or not
Trump supporters are deplorable we're
debating how many of them are and by the
way Hillary Clinton was dead wrong about
this half the Trump gang is trying to
pull off the neat trick of making
deplorable into a Red Badge of Courage
while simultaneously scoring martyred
points by insisting it was an
inappropriate attack it's not going well
somebody asks Mike I Robot pence if he
would agree merely that David Duke is
deplorable and Pence seems offended by
the question and says he's not in the
name-calling business whereupon his
buddy Republican Senator Mike Lee of
Utah tells pence he at least must call
Dukes racism deplorable and the Trump
campaign must repudiate the alt-right
and then campaign manager Kellyanne
Conway tries to pivot away to Hillary's
health by claiming Secretary Clinton
lied about her pneumonia
unfortunately when pressed about whether
Trump should release his full medical
records
she seems offended and says everybody
even Trump has a quote right to privacy
apparently completely unaware that less
than three weeks ago Trump offered to
release his detailed medical records to
dr. oz because Doctor Who is not filming
locally then Trump makes a fool of
himself by deciding not to release the
full thing to dr. oz and then he goes on
dr. oz anyway in hands dr. oz a piece of
paper and Oz reads briefly from it says
267 pounds and for all we know the paper
could have been Taco two gold menu and
while that gap is still echoing the
deplorable 's against steel the stage
video spreads of a protester getting
grabbed by the neck and punched by a
trump supporter during his speech in
Asheville whereupon they eject the held
not the holder and then a 69 year old
woman after the same speech tells a
Trump supporter that if Trump gets
elected the guy had better learn Russian
and the first words he should learn in
Russian should be haha so he allegedly
decks the woman who
apparently injured when the punch sends
her crashing into her own portable
oxygen tank at this kinder gentler Trump
campaign well it is kinder gentler the
Trump supporters aren't all wearing the
same colored shirts yet this comes as
the campaign had seemingly pivoted to
fewer big events with dangerous crowds
in order to tamp down all the noise
about deplorable what was that exactly
the Hillary Clinton said about them
again racist sexist homophobic
xenophobic Islamophobic and your point
but forget the supporters your moment
what about the advocates racist
well the co-chair of Trump's campaign in
New York former Republican nominee for
governor here Carl Paladino on Twitter
Lynch Loretta Lynch it was a typo by a
staffer they explained but six years ago
he sent out a video of an African tribal
dance the email was titled Obama
inauguration rehearsal sexist well Trump
himself talking about megyn kelly or
Mika Brzezinski or Heidi Cruz or Carly
Fiorina homophobic Robert Jeffress the
Texas mega church pastor who led the
prayer at a trump rally in June a year
after he said gay rights quote will pave
the way for that future world dictator
the Antichrist to persecute and martyr
Christians without any repercussions
whatsoever Islamophobic the New York
co-chair Palladino again on kazeer Khan
I mean if he's a member of the Muslim
Brotherhood or supporting the ISIS type
of attitude against America there's no
reason for Donald Trump to have to honor
this man and xenophobic ubiquitous
campaign spokeswoman Katrina Pierson
four years ago perfect Obama's dad born
in Africa mitt romney's dad born in
mexico any pure breeds left if you say
pure breeds and you're not in a harry
potter film or at a dog show you have a
screw loose
these are campaign leaders surrogates
friends of mr. Trump if they're not
talking to a basket of deplorable who
are they talking to why would you have
them there you say stuff like that at
work you get fired you say that school
you get
ended but happily Trump is there to say
no it's okay to hate better than that
you can hate out loud we'll just call it
freedom of speech and make America great
again
Secretary Clinton originally postulated
that half of trumps supporters were not
deplorable and that's where she screwed
up because if you support Trump if you
think he should be President regardless
of how much he and his advocates hate
and mock and punch old women with
portable oxygen canisters if you're not
condemning this madness and repudiating
these deplorable people and you are not
racist
not sexist not homophobic not xenophobic
or not Islamophobic if you're supporting
him not for those things but in spite of
them you are even more deplorable the
correct number Secretary Clinton is not
50% it's a hundred that's the closer I'm
Keith Olbermann watch this space